[音楽]
ある日の事だしな
所沢くんな
こんなことを言い出したのですね
んフロロ
[音楽]
p えっ
寒いですねぇ
問9分シンジシンジ年そっかぁ
そう小指とかこの子いつも一人だし
友達もダークネス井上も東京に行っちゃったしなぁ
ここはひと肌脱いでありますかます
なかったん
俺がなんとかしてやるようん
[音楽]
だから
待っててくれ
th
[音楽]
ん
すごいん
[音楽]
はーはっはっは
a
4つ
えっ
ところぞ
連れてきたさ
ん
[音楽]
5分よし負けていきます
どうやったら許可も出てきちゃってるなんて頑張ってここからわけよ
いきそうなってるはところぞ
ran
うんバッハ
なんでまだまだった山田せた
rar はっはっは
ちょっとああああああああっ
まずこれ難しいな出てき方がいい
あったからねそういうのじゃないんだよそういうのじゃないんだよ
ええええええ
voodoo
スーラー
[音楽]
あえっ
所沢の彼女ですん
[音楽]
色やべーなこれすごいあの袋から出たばっかりでちょっと不細工です
徐々にかわいくなっていくとは思うんですけど作るから出たばっかりでは不細工な
ちょっと見る瞳するところがあります
寄り添ってはい
変わっ
かわいいああ
ステッチはいというわけでダウンして井上
紫色位友達がずっといたと思うんですけどもあの子ためしばらく東京から帰って来ない
ですちょっと所沢が寂しいなった髪 c だということで今回ところ座の恋人の
[音楽]
名前と使用者
いやーいい名前どうしようえっと
山岸めぐみちゃんです
よろしくお願い致します
はい
なぜフルネームですが良かったこれでた文庫ドコモも
この笑顔ちゃんだか久しぶりにこんな背筋がピンとしたところ座を見た気がするんです
けどやなかなかお似合いだと思いますよ可愛いな
[音楽]
君たちお似合いだねがっつりを切れたと思いますや良かったなところがお前にエグゼ
あああ9
[音楽]
なんでびゅーん
ハーイいいいおにゃうにゃいほにゃよに愛をにあるというわけでちょっと寂しそうだっ
たんでところ座の恋人を準備してあげました
本当にかわいいな
うわぁ1人は
ani よつかありますかはい
ちかりの木ぞ
[音楽]
誓いのキスを
ジャブって
めでとうございます
快適でこれからですねところ里めぐみちゃんのお二人をどうぞよろしくお願い致します
by 葉っぱ
[音楽]